I was wishing to have a little
more of that floating around in me.
It's a bizarre heritage.
You know the idea that there
was a different type of
human that bread with Homo
sapiens and that there's like little
bits and pieces of it floating around in
Peabo. Yeah, and and people
discuss them. People discuss.
I was having an argument the other day
where they see a need and or tall or
neanderthal and everyone
grows up saying neanderthal.
It's one of those things you're supposed
to switch once you realize how you're
supposed to do it. Right. Neander tall
by just can't get comfortable with it.
I go back and forth.
There's a lot of words that like that
where I know you're supposed to do it by
can't get comfortable with it because I
feel like it makes you sound pretentious.
Does it's like rolling your
r's and certain Spanish words,
but we had this idea that the,
we had this idea of the
neanderthals as unsuccessful.
Right? Right. It's there. These
brutish thugs that died out,
but they had a 600,000
year run in Europe alone.
600,000 years longer run than homosapiens
of actually existed. Yeah. Yeah.
So whatever's, I don't know
that we're going to hit, like,
I don't know that we're going to
match up and have that run. Well,
we'll probably have a 23
and me for whatever the fuck
is after us and they just
look so many back then
fuck the human, like, oh,
one of those crazy war monger can rapists,
thieving humans died out.
It turns out they didn't totally die out,
overrun with the motions
and lies and they,
someone somewhat of a superior race
infiltrated the humans and banged one of
them. Yeah. It's, it's, it's
funny to look at that, uh,
that understanding of, of those,
that understanding of those people,
um, an end up to have the site
to picture in your mind's eye,
even though he can't picture it.
Like what was looked like when
they were hooking up someone are,
you know,
like anatomically kind of
behaviorly modern humans were
hooking up with neanderthals was that was,
how is it perceived by their peers?
I bet the people that we think of as
people back then, like you know George,
the animal Steele is no George animal
Steele is a very famous pro wrestler from
back in the day. And uh, oh,
I thought you're going to say it was a
paleontologist or an anthropologist was
the wrestler. He's a
wrestler, pro wrestler.
Very famous guy who could
be a fucking case man.
Like legitimately could be a
cave man. Yeah. See if you, uh,
you got a good image of him.
Now this is what I think when I think of
people now give me a full body one day
go, oh, when I think of people, he's
hanging on to some homo sapiens,
homo sapiens from, you
know, 200,000 years ago,
I think a George the animal Steele,
I think they were something like that.
So the idea of George fucking a
neanderthal check, not that far off.
I think our ideas like that.
Like Dan rather would be out
there banging some monkey lady.
I just don't think, I don't think that's
the case. Like look at George's body.
I mean, Jesus fucking Christ.
He's got the hairiest shoulders.
I've ever seen an a man. So
he's still alive. I do not
know. I don't believe he is.
I hope he's not listening right now. I
don't believe he is. Oh, he's a legend.
Legend in the world
with the pro wrestling.
So it's going to take more news to
hurt his feelings. I don't give a fuck.
He's a legend. But uh, when I was in a kid
in high school, oh he's, he's old as far.
Yeah. He's a pro. Well those guys, they
all, that's a hard way to make a live man.
He died at age 79. He had
a good run. Yeah. That's a
good run for, for those guys.
That's a fucking hard way to make a
living. But have we were talked about, uh,
the, the idea of neanderthals
is like having a cot,
a confrontational hunting style. No,
I don't like we have, cause when,
when,
when anthropologists look at the,
the skeletal remains of neanderthals,
they see this sort of suite of
this pattern of injuries on them.
And a researcher was looking at the types
of fractures that they have on their
bones and where the fractures occurred
and the breaks and cracks and their
skulls.
He was looking at all this and wound up
working with a doctor who had a lot of
exposure to rodeo riders,
bull riders,
and the doctor was,
was observing the way in which that suite
of injuries was very familiar to him
from rodeo riders, the types of
breaks and the location of brakes.
And this guy has this
idea that they had a,
like a very confrontational hunting style,
um,
that they were like mixing it up with
big animals and an earth thing they found
is that when you're looking at
skeletal remains from early people,
you still see that separation
in the saxes, right. That, that,
that the males would suffer injuries
with a greater prevalence than females.
But with the neanderthals it seems
like they didn't have the sort of like
duplicity of roles.
So the females,
the females have the same prevalence of,
of these types of injuries. And so
maybe they didn't have that, the,
they didn't share that division of labor
where the females as large as the males.
Yeah. I don't know the answer to that. So
we know that they had stone tools, right?
The crude stone tools,
but we don't know whether or not they
had anything that could launch them.
Like they didn't have did.
They would do we know if they had spears,
I don't believe that they've found
they had addle addles. Right.
And I don't know if they were hafting
materials, but they were doing,
they were doing art.
Um,
and I think there's a little bit of
a debate about whether they're doing
representational art, but they
were doing art. They were doing,
they were probably making jewelry. And
he's like, these are all things that as,
as we kind of like wake up to
what these people really like,
and it paints like a more complicated
picture. There's even the steering,
I don't know if this held any water, how
long it was fashionable for, but yeah, it,
this really long history of,
it was extremely long history of hundreds
of thousands of years in neanderthal.
You know,
occupation in Europe and then it seemed
to be that I remember someone putting
forth this idea that it seemed to be
that there was this flourishing of
advancement that was contemporaneous
with the arrival of our own ancestors in
Europe is though,
uh,
they were being exposed to or seeing are
and seeing jewelry and mimicking this
from these new invaders
that were coming in.
But I don't know where
that idea sits right now.
I don't know if it's been
dispelled because of other
discoveries and everything
that has an interesting
idea that they would then,
it kind of paints this really sad picture,
right?
That they would be sort of in the autumn,
you know,
of their existence and
here's these adorned people
showing up with these amazing
tool kits and all of these abilities and
kind of struggling to start to catch up.
You know, it'd be like the
country Bumpkin, you know,
go into the big city and,
yeah.
Well there was also this idea,
I think up until very recently
that neanderthals were
not as violent as humans,
uh,
as homosapians.
But now there was an article that was
published just a couple of days ago that
new evidence shows that neanderthals
like internees Anda tall violence between
each other. It was just as
bad as homosapians. Yeah. And,
and find that in evidence of cannibalism.
Oh yeah. There was a lot of that right.
Scraping of inside of the
skulls indicative of tools.
Oh.
Adblocker got busted.
They get us every time with the
fucking ad blocker. Yeah. Um,
what does it say? Humans are
just as violent as neanderthals.
Are you familiar with the writer John
Muallem? No. You'd like his stuff? Yeah.
He wrote a really beautiful piece about,
he wrote a really beautiful piece
about neanderthals not long ago. Okay.
I fucked it up.
What they're saying is that modern
humans were just as prone to violence as
neanderthals.
I don't have a problem where I think
I'm conflating this with something else
that I read about Inter,
uh, interspecies violence.
Nando tall on neanderthal violence.
The other thing that's weird about
them is they had bigger brains than us.
They have bigger brains and
they would be like five,
seven and weighed 200 pounds. Just
jacked. Just a little gorilla thing,
you know,
it'd be great to see it.
There was a really dumb theory that was
being bounced around a few years ago.
It was really hilarious about
how we wiped out. We, uh,
assumed that neanderthals, because you
don't have any soft tissue samples,
we assume that neanderthals
looked similar to humans,
but because of the very different
shape of their skull this guy had,
instead of giving them European looking
white skin, turned them into a gorilla,
turned them into a giant muscle
bound gorilla that preyed on people.
And this was like,
I believe this guy was an,
is actually was a professor and it
seemed almost like a goof at first.
You remember this, Jamie? We
pulled this up a few times,
like killer neander tall theory
think you call it. But yeah, it was,
he had drawn this thing black,
like a gorilla with like giant muscles
all over the place and these big crazy
eyes and that it painting
neanderthals as a Predator of humans.
And that's why we wiped him out.
Yeah. But my limitations as,
uh,
see I was gonna say my limitations as an,
as an anthropologist,
I'm certainly not an anthropologist that
I'll just do dude who's interested in
it. But one of my limitations is
I'll here theories floated. Okay.
And I don't follow them long enough to
see which ones have any traction. Right.
I'll just read about him and, and
I don't, I don't take it as Gospel,
but I'll read about it and I'll be like,
that's interesting.
And it was sort of like
shaped my understanding of it,
but then I don't keep track of it.
Like I try to really follow the story
of like the peopling of the Americas.
So when it comes to, to the human
history of the Western Hemisphere,
I sort of follow and like ideas.
We'll get floated and I'll track the
idea to see where it lands in terms of
scholarly consensus. But on other
stuff, like with neanderthals,
I'm always a sucker for
a neanderthal story,
but I don't track what ideas that float
up or just very quickly denounced as
being complete rubbish. Mm. Yeah. It's
a weird one. You know, it's a, it's,
it takes time to get,
it takes time to follow this stuff.
Go and go to that other picture. That's
what it is. Them, them and a us. Yeah,
but look at soon as some of his images,
look at that image that he
has on the cover of the book.
Like those are the idea that
there some way better ones.
There's some way better images
where they drew of a full body ones.
They had a,
is it in the article?
Was a link to the show website
from a different article. Just go,
go to that and then go
to images because a,
there was some really bizarre fucking,
yeah, there it is. Upper left hand corner.
This is what this guy, yeah. Well
that thing he's got going on.
That thing is not making art.
You don't think so?
No. He's making meat, man. Come on. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's pretty preposterous.
But neanderthals didn't
have fangs like that.
Now did they know what it is that he's,
he morphing in the end it all into a
gorillas that was trying to do, oh,
that's a how I, okay. Monkey Gorilla
neanderthal. But yeah, but like, oh,
it's got it snarling with, it's
fucking vegetable. Eaton teeth.
Anyway, it's, it's a,
and then there's the,
do we even know what those Denovo
eons to s, how do you say that word?
The one from Russia? Yeah. They don't have
any idea what they looked like, right?
No, I don't feel like someone pinky
bones and shit. You know they have that.
That one's not that one.
I don't know.